ils sont de nouveau devant le collège
pour manifester eux ce sont les parents
d'élèves inquiet de ne pas être entendus
on nous propose qu'une seule classe de
5e l'année prochaine et seront 33 donc
c'est ingérable pour les enfants enfin
pour les profs et donc on n'est pas
content on aimerait de classe l'année
prochaine cette semaine un collège mort
c'est à dire qu aucun élève n'est venu
cette semaine et on remercie les profs
d'ailleurs qui sont en grève aujourd'hui
une opération collège mort qui a débuté
lundi dernier avec une grande
manifestation dans les rues d'arnay le
duc aujourd'hui le mouvement des parents
reçoit le soutien des enseignants qui se
sont mis en grève ce jour ils dénoncent
la baisse continue de la dotation
horaire on a perdu plus de 1000 heures
année sur sur deux ans cette année en
organe des élèves on a de quoi faire
deux classes de 5e 33 élèves pour une
classe c c'est trop et on a continué à
nous enlever des heures le collège
d'arnay le duc souffre de réduction
d'horaires depuis plusieurs années ce
territoire bénéficie pourtant de soutien
de l'état
le maire de la commune solidaires du
mouvement des parents d'élèves ne tolère
plus la dégradation des conditions
d'enseignement
moi je souhaite réellement que on est
des perspectives parce que d'un côté
l'état nous aide en mettant en place des
dispositifs et puis d'un autre il ya ce
grignotage permanent comme un rouleau
compresseur de l'éducation nationale qui
nous enlève progressivement des heures
fois un moratoire pendant la durée du
quinquennat peut-être en disant voilà
ces zones là elles sont prioritaires il
faut les aider et on ne ferme plus deux
classes pendant les cinq ans à venir la
directrice académique des services de
l'éducation nationale nous a confirmé
que le sujet faisait l'objet d'un suivi
attentif
une audience est prévue le 4 juillet au
rectorat pour faire un dernier point sur
les